التعافي من كارثه دمار السد النوفا
كاخوفكا جنوبيه اوكرانيا قد يستغرق عقودا
وتاثيراتها تمتد من اوكرانيا للبلدان
المجاوره
الكثير من المناطق المبنيه على ضفاف النهر
اجتاحتها مياه خزان السد فيما يواجه سكان
المناطق المحاذيه عواقبا انهياره
دمار سد نوفا له تاثير سلبي على البيئه
اكثر من 30 الف متر مكعب في الثانيه من
المياه تدفقت وغطه الكثير من المساحات
الخضراء وسط تحذيرات من تغير النظم
البيئيه للابد وجفاف المنطقه الزراعيه
دمار سد نوفاكا خوفكا سيغير حتما من طرق
اعتماد اوكرانيا على مواردها الطبيعيه
فمياه السد كانت تغذي 80% من زراعه
الخضروات والفاكهه كما ان خزان نوفا
كخوفكا كان قلب احد اكبر انظمه الري في
اوروبا تدميره يعني التاثير على الصادرات
الغذائيه لبقيه العالم
سيؤدي اكتساح الملوثات في المجاري المائيه
لظهور امراض معديه وشح المياه الصالحه
للاستهلاك البشري
ستؤدي وفق خبراء جيولوجيين لاعاده تشكيل
خريطه اوكرانيا ودفع المدن من مواقعها
والاخلال بالتوزنات البيئيه الحساسه
لم يكن هناك تهديد النووي مباشر لضمار سد
نوفاكا الا ان نحو 150
داخل المحطه الكهربائيه تسربت الى نهر
نيبرو ووصلت مياهه لبرك التبريد في اكبر
محطه للطاقه النوويه في اوروبا مع جميع
تلك المخاطر تبقى مساله قياس تداعيات دمار
السد نوفا غير محسوبه لحين بدء جرد
الخسائر الفعليه
لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخج
والقس اشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات